ratatouille ii Pixar film directed by
Brad Bird and funny enough the second
film to mostly star a human cast even
though the main character himself is not
human our hero is a little rat played by
Patton Oswalt he has an extreme
fascination with the human culture
especially their food
well maybe not fascination more like an
obsession
he loves human food he loves to learn
how to cook he loves to make great art
out of special ingredients but the rest
of his family and his clan tell him to
stay away from humans and shut up and
eat his garbage eventually the racket
separated from his family and actually
comes across one of his favorite
restaurants sad news is that the chef of
that restaurant recently passed away and
now it's being taken under control by a
chef who isn't really that good and on
top of that is very power hungry so our
hero feels he can at least go in and
help out with some of the dishes but
ultimately gets caught he's captured by
a janitor named linguini who everybody
now thinks is the one who conjured up
the dishes which everybody seems to like
linguini puts together very quickly that
it was the rat who doctored it up and
eventually they form a partnership the
rat finds a pretty funny way of
controlling linguini by pulling his hair
and somehow controlling his arms much
like a puppet show the rat has total
power over the chef and makes it appear
like he's the one that's cooking all
these incredible dishes
from there gosh a ton of stuff happens
it's a conspiracy but who really owns
the restaurant there's a chef that gets
fired there's a critic who wants to come
and destroy the restaurant by giving it
a bad review there's the reuniting the
rat with his family there's a moral
about stealing there's a romance a bunch
of colorful characters they're trying to
be squeezed in on the side it's on Todd
much like The Incredibles I really wish
some parts got more focus than others
like I love these chefs I like how they
all have these very unique backstories
but they're really rushed I wanted more
of them I wanted to have more
interaction but it's all sort of pushed
aside for linguini who honestly I don't
think is that very interesting a
character he's just sort of your
everyday doofus nothing really makes him
stand out from any other doofus in
Pease there's a chef play pretty well by
Janeane Garofalo is pretty entertaining
the critic is one of the best designs
I've ever seen in an animated movie
though is it me or is he just that guy
from the Sleepy Hollow cartoon well
either way he looks awesome
the dead chef who used to own the
restaurant comes back as a figment of
the rats imagination and I think that's
a friggin great idea I think they should
have done that in Hunchback with the
gargoyles it's funny it's clever it's
touching and it's actually sort of an
interesting dive into the rats psyche I
thought that gave a very unique touch
but again these are the elements I serve
a wish got more focus a lot of it is
still focusing on the villain chef who
again is just sort of a boring villain
chef the rat family which again is just
serve a boring rat family and the
relationship between the rat and
linguini which is okay but I think could
have been a lot stronger the movie
saving grace though is its atmosphere
every shot just looks like something out
of a beautiful painting look at those
warm colors look at the contrast against
the purple skies look at France Oh God
look at France and once again the
designs of the human characters are very
Brad bird they looked like they were
drawn first and then put into a computer
which gives a lot more personality
speaking of personality I will not dare
give away the ending of this film to me
it is one of the most perfect endings
that can ever be given to a movie it's
funny it's heartwarming it's clever the
words being said are actually pretty
thought-provoking not just for critics
but for people in general wanting to
judge something and it gives you that
warm fuzzy feeling that only something
as good as Disney can give you I think
this mixed with the atmosphere is what
makes the film especially strong does it
have troubles like I said before yeah
and I think they are some serious flaws
but oh man the stuff that's good I can't
even say how good it is there's some of
my favorite scenes and I can listen to
that last dialogue from the critic over
and over again it's one of my favorite
moments in all cinema so despite its
troubles ratatouille is a delicious
delight that I'm sure to return to many
times in the few
you